uh Brendan be fish I presume not his
real name on Twitter asks speaking
personally do you believe that Robert
Ned and John Aaron were justified in
their rebellion against the Mad King if
it were you would you have stayed loyal
to the Targaryen
people in the audience are freaked out
by this question I don't think I would
have stayed loyal to to the Mad King do
I think they were justified yeah yes and
no I don't like to provide easy answers
today I'd like to make I like to make
the reader wrestle with the question and
and think about it because some of these
questions never are easy when we
encounter them in in real life it's been
interesting coming back here to Chicago
because I was I spent 10 years in
Chicago in the Chicago area I was at
Northwestern from 1966 to 1971 up in
Evanston and then I was in Chicago from
71 to 76 and if you look at that era
particularly the early part of that era
the 60s it was sometimes known in the
history books for you young people
who've read about it in history as the
turbulent 60s there was a an altercation
going down in Vietnam that some of us
didn't like there were a lot of protests
and demonstrations people in the streets
by the tens of thousands by the hundreds
of thousands in some cases and I look
back on that era now and and you know I
asked myself that question did we were
the protests justified did we do the
right thing did we do the wrong thing
should we have gone further - should we
you know I was very much a clean for
dream guy I still believed in the
American system and
you know elections and let's electri
McCarthy and put an end to Vietnam war
that way there were more radical people
who wanted to destroy the state and tear
it all down rebuild it you know and when
I look at all the things that happened I
don't know
it was a confused time and it's still a
confusing time to look back in history
maybe a hundred years from now when
everybody who participated in dead will
be able to sort it out and find the
answers but his violence ever justified
to oppose evil in the world if so to
what extent is violence justified and
these are the questions that Ned and
Robert had to had to deal with there was
no doubt that the Mad King was mad he he
was you know paranoid and violent and he
was abusing his power and Westeros has
no Magna Carta or anything like that it
was no way to handle this within the
rule of law but was what they do
justified especially when you consider
that it was triggered by a personal
grievance the the execution of Ned's
father and and brother was really a
thing that radicalized as we would have
said in the 60s Ned and man put him in
in opposition to it Robert was just
rolling for a fight and it might affect
that he'd lost his girlfriend so you
know the personal informs the political
I don't as a reader I like the writers
who ask questions and get you to think
and I try to do that as a writer I don't
necessarily like the writers who give
answers as often I don't agree with the
answers they seem wrong to me in some
cases so they seem overly simplistic but
questioning is important Theodore
sturgeon who was one of the great great
science fiction writers of the Golden
Age and a real individualist and
freethinker I think he had a slogan
which was called asked and that's asked
the next question and he wore it had a
medallion that he wore in the last of
life a big shoe with an arrow through it
that stood for ask the next question and
I always admired sturgeon and his his
views on that your answer about not
giving answers was a very good answer
thank you excellent ok another question
this is from Lucifer means light bringer
which I also presume is not this
person's government name you have
created several notable in world
mythical figures which seemed to serve
as archetypes that are the main
characters echo at times can you say a
few words about your use of myth and
internal folklore and the way those
things interact with the main story and
characters yeah I've had a lot of fun
well it's it's part of the
world-building process I mean every
world every culture has its has its
myths as its legends as its heroes you
know what I suspect everybody in this
room even if you haven't read the books
or somebody knows who Robin Hood was or
a little about him or King Arthur and or
maybe some of the American myths Paul
Bunyan or spider-man or Superman right
right and we refer to them occasionally
we make references to them it's
sometimes amazing to think of the extent
to which some of these ancient myths and
ancient characters permeate or our
culture you know we watch football and
somebody blows out his Achilles tendon
we're referring to a character from
Homer you know who existed if he existed
all three thousand years ago and you
know his only vulnerability was his heel
and because of that we're talking about
an injury to a football player it's it's
amazing so a mythical world obviously I
can't reference Achilles or Paul Bunyan
or spider-man
but it has to have its own heroes and
its own legends and and I try to put
them in to give that flavor I had a lot
of I don't know how many of you have
read my latest Westeros book fire and
blood
which is thank you fire and blood is a
little different because it's it's not
part of a world of Ice and Fire a song
of ice and fire it's a fake history book
imaginary history about the first
hundred and fifty years of Targaryen
dynasty and it's written in world that's
written by archmaester gil Dane that a
citadel 300 years after many of the
events which he's chronicling so like a
real historian like someone writing now
about the American Revolution well he
wasn't there for the American Revolution
he has to go back and and look at
primary sources so did our mr. Gil Dane
and what you find out when you do that
is the primary sources disagree they
have different versions of events one
person said it happened this way another
person said no that never happened it
happened this way and archmaester Gil
Dane trying to be good historian is
replicating all of the different
versions and that was a lot of fun for
me because I could play with the whole
concept of history history being told by
the winners history being cleaned up and
made politically correct or religiously
correct and I could present different
versions of of the various stories and
that was I enjoyed that I think some of
my readers enjoyed that too particularly
the version of history told by mushroom
to court fool who always told everything
in the most sexual the visibility is a
shocking way possible
usually with himself as the hero and you
have a history degree so that was
helpful
well I thought history degree but I
think the history minor and and I love
history I read a lot of I'm not a
historian by any means I'm just a
history nerd suppose you would say